use insight that's a really good idea
actually
[ __ ] sake why oh
my god thank you nikki that's actually
so
infuriating what the [ __ ]
thank you okay let's get the rest of it
jesus
christ i used insight when i
wasn't like focused
come on there could have been some
indication that's
okay fine we'll just keep going i won't
be a still loser anymore
oh wait i'm gonna do the clock so we can
both get through at the same time
thank you nikki
why not i mean everyone loves power
personally i would have liked some sort
of visual
hints like you know a scratch or some
some sort of
wear and tear like it's obviously been
used quite a lot
i'll never get used to this
nope it doesn't work i'm gonna see some
projected footage
i hate to think what kind of photos need
this much secrecy
oh we did this in the beginning of the
game
don't forget about the red light light
five seconds
time in each tray three seconds yeah we
did this before
hey terry it's like the haunted mansion
at disney
only more demonic i don't think i've
ever been to the haunted mansion
are you talking about um tower of terror
is that okay
i know how this works i need three
liquids to develop the photo yay
a trillion fixture network problems you
literally missed
nothing so good timing welcome
okay so how do we do this again
like five seconds time at least tray
three seconds i will
just pick it up put it in the trays i
remember we
what okay yeah we put it here before
didn't we
then we did this for five seconds one
two
three four five
uh what's looks like there's a train
missing oh
got an illuminated photo
right so we need to get everything to
put into the trays
okay that's one
two more to go that was easy
hello sidney uh
this should come in handy there's the
tray
hope he's not using it as a textbook
malev's maleficent
hammer of witches cool
okay oh is that pentagram
i could sense something stirring behind
that symbol
like a gust of wind moving a curtain
it's getting stronger i can feel it
seeping through creeping into my mind
if once out i cannot get out i won't let
it
i mean it cannot get up anyway
even if it means no i'll find another
way
killing yourself
banishing yourself to another dimension
suppressing huh
not sure i like the sound of that maybe
that's what he's going to try and do to
you
or he needs us to like
i don't know
distract the dead so he can suppress
better okay that's all of them
okay so let's put this where's the tray
put the tray down
uh i don't know which one i want
uh okay
great and then we'll put this stop over
here
all right so that's the fixer stop and
this must be developer
okay so let's do three seconds in each
one two three
oh god no take it jesus
that was more than three seconds and
then
one two three
one two three
what the hell
there we go now it's movie time
who's there she looks great
that's creepy is that bed is that the
kid's bedroom
what what the [ __ ] is this
this hat
and your strength
are you all right
yes use your power
oh
this is the only problem with playing
games once a week
i think it must be lt or arty i'm hoping
[Music]
so
can i pause wait don't go
okay pause i want to look at the
[ __ ] ah there we go there we go there we
go there we go there we go there we go
come on
i was not prepared
it looks really bloody cool though
okay don't go oh god
don't leave me here
alone naked
all right there you go keep going you
little girl
oh god
how many times is this guy gonna kill me
and i'm still gonna keep coming back
i try fight back i guess
wait don't go oh god
don't need me here alone
near
what do you mean
go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go
i don't have any power left
not a fan of light huh
[ __ ] figures yeah that was easy
[ __ ] figures
charge up
i just got an achievement uh called
running simulator
i thought it was quite funny
[Music]
i don't think this
okay [ __ ] it let's go
you can't see me you can't see me
okay nevermind
why don't i run faster than this like
this is not okay
why how am i supposed to get around you
little
[Music]
[ __ ]
okay maybe if i get around him like
at the very beginning then because it
looks like i have one
chance to kill it
sneak attack can i do that
that would be very nice if i could do
that
how am i supposed to know like when i
have
powers this little
chargey bar i guess her arm is a
charging bar but
okay i'm going to stay away from that
rolling [ __ ] skull
because it's just the troll in it
not here
[Music]
where am i supposed to go
okay wow
see he just will pass me there so i know
how to get oh [ __ ] out
[ __ ] out
[Music]
[Music]
stay sneaking okay i just don't know
where there's no
obvious place where to hide you just
have to stay
crouched and then hope that it's gonna
walk past you
[ __ ] sucks
really feels like you have no option
here
hidden collision
uh
so
okay this isn't bad maybe i can do it
i wish i had camera control
i don't want you to train me on i don't
want you to try me on
this is so [ __ ] scary because i know
that if i die i'd [ __ ] die
and this is the press i've got please
don't get me
keep going that way yes good man
come to me fountain of goodness yeah
so nice
um
what the [ __ ] was that it was mental
i don't think we have any power left now
either sad
this game went from like no enemies
very narratively focused just like okay
when there are enemies around
you better be careful
most people spend their whole lives
seeing only a fraction of our reality
lucky them
back in the beginning i have spent
my whole life looking beyond the edges
of our reality
even as a child i
saw things that would break a grown man
eventually i grew into it
it became my normal
but that thing
it was anything but normal
what did you know to look and
encountered
this ravenous
i felt lost
i came to neva looking for answers and
all i got was more questions
what was that monster
who was thomas and what did he want from
me
yeah yeah she's basically saying what
we're all thinking
harry anne
marianne
i woke up with icy water in my veins
i wanted nothing but to get out of there
to just get up and run until my legs
give out
until my lungs collapse
but i knew i couldn't
it wouldn't have solved anything
and besides sadness
needed my help
what's her necklace
there's someone there there's a light
through the
game have you seen that before
mary and happy
you are okay
sadness is that you oh
she's are you okay to us what was that
thing
hello
richard
richard no sadness
the man i'm looking for is named thomas
who's richard
day room
it's like when i'm playing phasmaphobia
and i'm trying to talk to the ghost show
me the way
and it doesn't make any sense
oh
i've read all this yes
i remember
oh this music is so good
it's moving it's like bouncing around my
ears oh you probably hear it too
actually
i'll shut up
the safest place for younguns really
highly doubt that somehow
all right find a way through there what
now
this game is quite cinematic i i am
enjoying it
it's family time
holidays in the country
[Music]
first thomas then richard
before i knew it i was looking for a
bunch of strangers
at least sadness was still with me in a
way
metaphorically
oh yeah so we can't go into our ghost
realm now
i don't have that capability anymore
it only happens oh god
it's everywhere how many people died
here
my t-shirt is from amazon
you want me to go down there
there's a door open over there
okay
let me be frank this case is
problematic my superiors want it to go
away
i want it to go away you can see how
your statement complicates that
comrade i'm
yes i understand
some things don't just go away they
stick
they echo
so
this is a really cool place
i swear i could just hear breathing in
my ears
don't like that
okay let's get up
get on up but get on up get on the scene
and get on
up
there's a lot of blood on the floor here
what am i doing with this thing
i think i think i should have hold it
actually
can i not pull it out again
get her a little hand i don't think i
can actually pull it so maybe
i pushed ahead for a reason maybe i can
climb on it
getting again the scene again
cover your nose try not to look at them
the sooner we're done the sooner we can
get out of this place
ah definitely didn't need to feel that
postcards my dearest i wish this was it
the moment i plucked up the courage and
actually send this one
seems so easy just throw it in the
mailbox
then why can't i someday i promise
i love you with all my heart so he was
like
saving his postcards to send to
his wife i'm guessing and uh
she never said that for some reason i
wonder why why can't you send them
interesting
it's a very bloody locker
if i didn't know better i'd say there
was a zombie inside
or at least a dead present
light switch taunting me
a troubled man francis
what am i supposed to do with you once
knew was shut down you begged me to keep
you on
said you needed time to sort things out
said you could be useful
but now i know you're just using me as
an excuse
but there's letters you keep writing i
know you never send
never sent a single go that one so this
is thomas
talking to the groundskeeper maybe the
groundskeeper is the other person was
supposed to be looking for richard in
the day room
i don't know maybe not um no because
he said he signs it with f doesn't he
yeah which would be francis right
francis the groundskeeper
anyway who are you kidding frank hell
as long as you're here i can at least
keep an eye on you
make sure you don't get hammered and
pass out in a snow drift
guess it's the least i can do get up
frank too scared to live
too stubborn to die sometimes i feel
guilty using you like this
so you're using frank
but then i remember i need all the help
i can get
okay
is the thing chasing us frank
maybe he did some weird like
witchy voodoo on the groundskeeper i
don't
i'm reaching i'm preaching i don't know
what i don't know
locked locked
hey marianne you look like [ __ ]
that's a weird little uh insert
okay
are those bolt cutters
that might be useful if only i could
reach them
sadness can you come climb this for me
please
hmm
oh my [ __ ] christ she heard me
whoa sadness
how did you
ah [ __ ]
oh
well that's my seven years bad luck
who's that did you see that
sounds like a person in the background
creepy little thingy
okay you're gonna play
hey wait up come on slowpoke
i've got an idea we're gonna show that
weirdo
what are you gonna do hmm
there were some kids here
well i mean sadness wasn't the only kid
you know sadness had friends
she told you that
hello anyone
so much blood what the hell
oh sadness
isn't it sadness or is it someone else
okay i think she wants us to get back
the way that we came perhaps
oh no
oh they stop they stop here
[Music]
for the doggy doggy dog dog
right
ready or not here i come
that voice
so where are you now then trail
i went to the doggy dog do you want to
dog
back up come on hurry oh there's
something up there
okay
i miss this little doll
what no it's fine
i'm sure they're here somewhere no
bernard wouldn't do that my dad's close
she's talking to herself again what a
freak hey don't talk about her like that
shut up bernard maybe it's her
seeing like spirits at a young age or
something
okay now we go
through here
the nurse she did it she killed them all
it was like
something possessed her is that really
what you want us to put on record it's
what i
saw i'm a nurse
but how
why
and i skilled everybody that's so good
bye and trillian thanks for coming
okay now do i do something with this
oh that's probably why i had to push it
because it's this little toy
here guys
come on it's dark in here this isn't
funny
i really don't think we should shut the
heck
up bernard guys
oh kids can be such [ __ ] sometimes
yes they're great
what is it you want to show me something
oh no
oh okay good it's not the bloody one
it's
the non-bloody one
what the hell it looks back at me
interesting
look at the reflection the cat is black
in the reflection
it looked back at me
why does that sound familiar
this is gonna she's gonna have like been
brought up here or something and just
forgotten about it right
oh damn is it oyster stuck
is that it is
something else
no i think that's it
where did i put that cat
here
can i just examine it
okay i have a cat
so i open up this one
[Music]
as i got closer to the mirror i felt a
slight tug
in my pocket i could tell there was more
to that figurine than just
carved uh we should look in the mirror
with the cat
like in the um illustration that we
picked up
i can feel it calling out to me
hello
use the cat
oh no i don't want to be on this side of
the wall
it was the first time that it ever
happened
i touched the mirror and crossed over to
the other side
salty sandwiches gone home medium
edition
what the hell is this place
the other side
but you're right it's like a place all
on its own isn't it
it's not mimicking
the layout of where we've just been
what's happening no no please mommy
oh god happened to you
wait i know you you were that boy
bernard was it how the hell can you know
that
he was trapped there just like i was
i knew his name but somehow that wasn't
enough to send him away
it was like a part of him was missing
i have nothing to put in his mouth
which is uh unfortunate
i'll come back for you dude
with your dummy
all these people they weren't just
killed
their spirits were ripped apart
broken beyond repair
maybe i can find the one bernard's
missing
oh right i need to look at his face
because he all wear like clay faces
which is
weird but
ah which way should we go let's go in
here
i don't think you can go forward anyway
oh hello
the spirit well i could use some of that
energy
yes
okay are we gonna go back to the other
cat figurine was the key
i can't pass through without it hello
henry hey that's where those bolt
cutters are
so close and yet so in a different
reality
wait the bugs come back oh they're
through here
okay let's do it
you ready guys
fear no evil what's a
person thing his mouth i guess it does
look like a bit of a trap
burn you little [ __ ]
this was yours wasn't it bernard come on
pick it up it's about time you got it
back pick it up
if you don't have all the time in the
bloody world
there you go
that's so cool
yeah it's actually pretty good that her
arm works as a um
like a charge at bar
keeps the head nice clean
okay dude i got your face
i'm sorry you had to go through all this
it's time for you to find peace
bernard thank you
even though you are such a meanie huh
it kind of looks like the one i used to
get through the mirror it's a sad cat
feels like it too sad kitty
oh that's so cool
sad kitty
okay oh
no
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm like no bye
i'll be so cool if you could see him
like through the mirror
just like oh
man that was [ __ ] scary what if i go
should i should i try and go back
through i don't think i can
she'll try and get back through no and
she was like
no no not doing it
no no
oh that was funny okay it was like use
expecto patronum
think happy thoughts
no no no i'm not going back there no
okay all right
you can dance if you want to
leave your friends behind
what no no
[ __ ] off your little chest
how do i turn off my life
my light's going crazy it's gonna give
me away the [ __ ] duck is duck sizzy
come on hold your breath you little [ __ ]
mongrel
oh no i thought
what it doesn't see the light okay well
that's good to know
and then what says use insight that's
actually a really good idea
i should probably do that but it's good
to know that he doesn't see the
flashlight
at least because i thought that was
gonna
skip me away instead i just gave me away
what no no
um
[Music]
oh my [ __ ] gods
oh dude does the light act like um
i don't know where it is i'm just
getting scared now
i think i should have gone this way
oh my [ __ ] god oh my [ __ ] god and
my [ __ ] god my [ __ ] god
my [ __ ] god i'm too scared can i get
can i not get behind like any other
[ __ ] cover are you [ __ ]
[Music]
yeah the light acts like the radio
in saturn hill there was no escaping it
when it flickers is when it's close
that's cool those are like very subtle
sun hill hints but then there's very
obvious ones
like the skin wall but i'm not
complaining i'm not complaining
oh there's those bolt cutters again oh
how am i going to get this blue gotta be
aware
great another mirror
hello
new details have emerged the situation
may be more
complicated than we expected no time to
explain
you'll get the full report once i get
back just leave it to me comrade
very meticulous of you comrade
locked right
so the only way i can go is to the
[Music]
mirror
oh is he like possessing her
is he just like torturing her
oh no there's more of them
what has it done to you
no names no faces
just like bernard
no what are you stop
this is is where he died
okay i still knew his name
if only i could see the other side of
this place
oh hands have fun
just go along
uh-oh this layout looks like it's for a
hide-and-seek sequence i don't enjoy
those
hopefully it's not
one can hope oh oh my god i scared
myself
some sort of a conference room
it's always the same
i gotta go the boating's about to start
you know what they say if you're early
you're on time
no i mean right now i can hear them
gathering across the hallway
yeah yeah i'll let you know how it went
that voice
that's the guy what guy
thomas richard
oh the guy that died who the bloody hell
is richard i'm so confused where's his
i'm sure i'll find out i'll stop whining
oh
an attendance list ah i'll bet the name
i'm looking for is here on this page
don't say lame
but which one is it
[Music]
nicholas
waldemar
boris
how are we going to whittle them down
oh maybe one of these will have a
a whispering insight
oh golden
i can't believe they sat me across from
boris okay so we got to figure out i
don't care whose nephew he is
he's just a sexist pig for all i care
and late as always
okay this is opposite boris
oh
which one is boris
maybe we can find some etchings on the
table or something
late as per usual
boris
boris that's the guy he was talking
about
oh i see seat number nine
this is it oh man i'm looking for it
lucky guess where he died
seat number four
that's it nicholas yes nicholas
okay nick let's get you out of here nico
nicole nicolas
right now that we have your name
let's get back into the scary world
[ __ ] freaking the [ __ ] out mate
i'm very shy
and where the other runs
say what i'm very anxious
i don't know if you can tell
okay we got one uh whose face is it do
you reckon oh it's about
this time for you to get some rest
you've earned it nicholas
thank you madam can you help me from the
stereo oh okay okay
yeah one down one to go
better get to it
hey indie jack
nothing here at least not in this world
oh i see
okay
i hate that this spooky thing can like
travel
what's this there we go oh i found it in
the
spirit world it's interesting okay
this is something new here
here we go
let's just have a look here first
oh we got another
postcard honey i miss you a lot
i really hope you can join me soon you'd
love it here the weather's great the
sun's shining the lake's beautiful
people are nice i don't think they're
nice
uh francis you think they're nice maybe
right now but we've just read a
anyway nice and dead oh
i should probably just read it all
before i make an assumption
all of them cool cool
something wrong with you francis
nope okay
there's another mirror there
but there's something around here oh i
don't think i can go
or maybe i can no no i can't
okay mirror time
this is very well done the ambience
basically like stepping into hell
oh already
i guess let's just
no i can't go anywhere fair enough
okay
oh it's just saved i don't know whether
to go any further
because i feel like i should call it a
night
maybe i should play a bit more oh i
don't know
yeah screw it i'll pay a bit more
i've had such a scary week this week
i've been reading um
the haunting of hill house the book that
the netflix series
is loosely based off is quite different
actually
but it's hands down i think the scariest
book i've ever read
and it's so short as well if you like
horror you should
really read it it's so so freaking good
but it's terrifying
i'm behind ya
and you keep me scared as [ __ ]
yes i do
[Music]
oh god please don't look here please
again
you ate people no more tea parties
don't look at me don't look at me
you don't like it when i look at you all
right
okay
who is he talking about is he talking
about that nurse
i'm getting close that woman was here
she was a ballerina was she what how do
you oh right
yeah we've seen these posters or maybe
she was the ballerina that was playing
that's pretty cool
this room has guy written all over it
in big sloppy letters well because they
have
guys clothes everywhere i guess so
nice card was vivienne one of your stars
okay last one i can barely feel my wrist
i don't care i just want to go to bed i
need to be alone
okay so she was he was her manager and
she was sick
just vivienne no
probably just a stage name definitely a
stage the artist
formerly known as vivienne is that a
bullet hole in the wall
there that's her room
someone couldn't even let her have her
privacy
i do not trust that the peepholes not in
a silent hill
game and especially not after the first
playthrough of this
oh i would be a bit more freaked out if
we could peek around
but we can't say
i'm just something's gonna happen
really i don't trust it
has anyone here played sand hill the
room
okay anyway that name
it's everywhere but that wasn't the real
you
yeah this was in her room
we just established this
well done you're genius
i know i can go through that mirror i
just want this is where it happened
all the places what is this like the
bathroom
you what are you
get out no
oh no i missed it what'd she just say
hello probably still no name
there's gotta be something you could try
her stage name
no no we'll get her name don't worry
okay let's find out who you really were
vivian vivienne
huh a page was torn out
i can't make out the numbers
mom we can just phone her mom be like
what was your daughter's name again
i can't quite remember george's house
niwa the resort and
what that is
hmm
ah maybe i guess one of these names
belongs to your true self
but which one is it neither one is very
video like
oh there's something bad partial numbers
one of these must have meant something
to her
i'll be on the other side this is going
to come we go into her bathroom
where's that peephole
i want to look at it from the other side
i still don't know her real name
just words sounds without meaning
where's that people
i guess we can't look at it from this
side
there a bunch of numbers some would say
but i sensed there was a lot more to
them
hello yes this is vivian
room 347 i want to make a complaint
there was a man here yes from the hotel
staff
frankly i think i smelled vodka on his
breath
he what that was the chief of staff
you know what never mind thank you
well it's a stressful job i guess
hello oh hey are they asleep
it's fine i know you're busy i'm busy
too
yeah it's tomorrow the big day
yep thanks i'll see you home
kiss them for me okay not exactly a
hotbed of
passion
broken up in her marriage or i guess
partnership
yes yes mother i know
i'm doing my best what
no i well what about my hard work
it's not always about you don't call me
victoria
you know i hate that is that her name
victoria
that was her given name but not the real
one
not to her okay
what number is this
oh my god ellie i thought you were
no no i'm really happy to hear from you
vicky why didn't you call sooner
you did but eugene
that slippery son of a [ __ ]
ellie she was very special to her
you don't need to be a medium to see it
so if he torey
it's you the real you
that's your name it made sense
really a name is more than what everyone
calls you
it's what you feel yourself to be
wait can i go through here now
i don't know what the best way back is
am i going i might wait
i want to look back through the peephole
again do you think anything could happen
if i look back through the i'm gonna go
look back through the people again
nothing's gonna happen but i i just
wanna look through people again
i just like beeping
so this is a room
[Music]
if i go through here
i don't know if i can get out this way
i just don't trust it i can never trust
peoples
okay
okay fine
i trust it
go about the other way
it's quicker
i'm not gonna lie it felt good
putting that curse of mind to good use
moments like that used to keep me going
now i'm not sure anymore
um i think we gotta go back through here
can you guys hear me okay by the way
hey ramita one for four
uh which way do i go now
back through here now
sweet thanks abe
here we go
it's okay you can be free now
tori thank you
thank you
you did it mariah sent them away
to a better place i hope hell
anywhere is better than here
we did it
oh hello what do we have here that's a
long time to get them but
you just let me pick you up no they're
in the wrong
dimension damn it
oh oh i think i might be able to pick
them up soon
a quiet girl this isn't that's just
other
fair enough
maybe restart mr rakaux
i just can't say names very well can i
it's being unreasonably
unreasonable to put it mildly i'm a
nurse
not a nanny i understand that he needs
someone to keep an eye on her
but i have my hands full as it is even
putting aside all my other duties
there's poor mr takowski to take care of
still i try to do my best at least the
girl's quiet
keeps to herself mostly likes talking to
her imaginary friends is this me
talking about me um
but i figure it's quite normal for
someone her age sometimes i can hear her
playing out full conversations and i
swear it sounds like two people talking
she really is gifted guess it runs in
the family
mr rakowick so is that her dad
let's just have a quick look i know i
should probably be going the other way
but
i don't know oh here we go yes
[ __ ] finally [ __ ] time to get back
to the day room
oh my god that trick that took a lot
longer than i expected it to
to be honest they found a cat
those are stuff
this place this is where it started
hello my love it's your favorite nurse
are you in there
it got to her first but
why
i'd never felt darkness like that before
that thing had been there it was where
it made its first kill
where it tasted death and liked it
did you use the nurse then
my poor poor mr takalski whatever
happened to you
the tests come back no signs of any
brain trauma or dementia
and still i look into your sad empty
eyes
and i have this awful feeling that
there's no one looking back
don't worry my love i'll take care of
you no matter what
i'll make sure you're as happy as can be
450 milligrams of
vel ben
is that the the nurse that fell in love
with mr takeowski that just went crazy
and killed everyone or was that a
different
different nurse
i feel like this should be a running
scene ah
thank god
so worth it i love you both cutters
now we're downstairs upstairs i guess
downstairs to the day room
oh yeah it was downstairs
kind of sounds like a spy name cutters
bolt cutters what
what that was the weirdest like
in a movie you don't use your real name
for
yeah okay sure
sure whatever you say it is
whatever you say
i can't use my bears anymore
marianne has an infatuation with the
bulk colors it's bolt
no it's cutters both cutters
what this is the weirdest like
voiceover ever
blooper
imagine you're a spy and they gave me
bolt cutters that's your
name yeah nothing is more um
peculiar like curious than uh
bolt colors they're like you definitely
made that up
mommy covers
am i going right yeah i am going the
hard way
okay marianne let's see what sadness
wanted me to see
that's good richard is richard right
did i already read this
i keep seeing it in my dreams the other
place
dust and death as far as the eye can see
a feeling of nothingness tearing at my
soul i wake up
choking feeling the dust browning
through my lungs
i beg for it to stop he says there's no
helping it
then again he would say that wouldn't he
maybe this is like how long lost dad or
something
they obviously share that same trait
it does seem like she was brought up
here
okay let's do this
all right here we go
that thing almost got me
what the hell is it it came from
shame from
helplessness from rage
rage it's like anger
but more once it got out
we couldn't stop it it ain't all of them
mary young
all of my friends your friends i'm the
only one
left it's it's okay sadness i'm here now
no no it'll eat you too
just like others i'll just replay let it
hurt you i promise
okay hey
why don't you tell me something about
this place
how sick
richard is he one of your friends
no but he was smart
maybe he could help you he was smart
wait is he a bad thing
happened to him i remember he became
hollow like a puppet
he oh
i remember marianne
i don't want to see him what why not
what what do you remember
no don't tell them don't tell anyone
you don't have to tell me but you should
still
come with me so that i can keep you safe
no
no marion the sadness ever again why did
you
bring me here
those cinematics then i realized
there was something she wanted me to see
but she was also [ __ ] tired of my own
eyes
those cinematics honestly they so good i
mean
they'd be impressed if if it was just
the same cinematic showing two different
versions of the same thing but the fact
that like
the center point moves depending on
which scene has more relevance
and um it changes
to show you like
how ridiculous everything looks in the
normal world versus how things actually
are
in the ghost world for instance like
it it lingered on the ball a lot longer
in the real world than it did on the
ghost world because it was looking at
sadness ah
it's so cool it's it's so i love it
i love it well done blueberry good one
dicky
the hell is all that goop
don't you think he would be better off
in a nursing home
what about his family richard doesn't
have any family
oh the poor man it's
like he's somewhere else we were close
once you know
i mean not that close but all right
i'll take care of him hollow like a
puppet
isn't that what sadness said
very special boy
i remember the first time i met him
working a simple factory job
still more of a boy than a man wide-eyed
constantly looking over his shoulder
like a scared animal
his parents had died in the war so
uprising
of what he'd gone through in the years
that followed he did not want to speak
and i never pressured him but it soon
became clear
he had no one else in the world i could
immediately tell that
despite his young age he had seen things
that no one his age
should i could immediately tell he was
special
he's a special boy he is sorry why do i
do stupid accents i gotta stop it it's a
hurricane
i gotta keep
okay
that's a really nice
gather round children i want you to meet
lillian
she's going to be joining our painting
class
why can't i play with my friends uncle
richard
your friends that's sadness oh
lillian i i promised your father you
would
spend some time with the other children
friends
yeah i don't think she really have any
friends lillian though
maybe we can help her get away because
we know her name
that was her right
sure it's gotta be there
a sheet of music well
at least part of it cool
thomas i've always been stunned by the
depths and complexity
of his imagination mesmerized by the
surreal dreamscapes his mind with weave
the way he describes them with every
minute detail
it was as if he had actually witnessed
all of it
as if something or someone pulled the
veil
and allowed him a peek beyond the edges
of our reality
an angel a demon is there really a
difference
i know it didn't matter to me as his
visions came alive on my canvas
some would say i used the boy to fuel my
waning creativity
but how could i not to let his unique
perspective
this bottomless well of the inspiration
the of inspiration
go to waste that would be an unfigured
proportion
so there's a mentor there's the troubled
man
so the troubled man is thomas the mentor
is richard maybe
and then frank is the groundskeeper
and richard was an artist and he
used
use thomas speak there's nothing else
around here
uh
i don't have any um
any power either so i can't
zap away those things
just gonna find one more piece of music
i guess
she's not saying anything
that globe there's a sense of
loneliness it feels
complete
that glow there's a sense of
loneliness it feels
very complete
it became a habit of ours we'd sit down
sketchbook at the ready
and then heath close his eyes and start
talking describing all the things he saw
in his mind's eye
the horror and splendor of worlds beyond
our own
what started out as an innocent exercise
in imagination
ultimately became a bottomless well of
inspiration
my hand wouldn't dare rest sketching
furiously as he described the
indescribable
for a while i wondered why he was so
eager to share his visions with me
to him they seemed to be a burden a
source of great pain and distress
but finally i understood he sought to
share them
with someone who saw them as a source of
beauty rather than madness
i guess that makes sense
is that it
there's nothing i can do with that glow
[Music]
outside
we should just
do the opposite of like
the opposite of that thing
i've read that one oh did i read the one
next to it
i spent a few years trying to steer him
in the right direction
trying to make him see the depth of his
potential
he kept refusing claiming that he was no
painter and
he saw our little get-togethers as
therapy rather than artistic expression
eventually i wore him down he agreed to
enter the university but on the
condition that
it would be his chosen field
and so he started on his way to becoming
an architect
at first i was rather skeptical thinking
that he was throwing away greatness for
mere competence
but deep inside i guess i was glad to be
the only one
to bring his visions to life and then he
met her
i painting sessions with him far and she
between
he no longer needed my help in dealing
with his inner
[Music]
don't funk with demons heart
[Music]
come on there's like one sheet of music
that i've still yet to find
i don't know what the sheet of music
will do
when there's a key a key would be nice
too
visions of the spirit world yes michael
i think i think what happened here is
there's a guy called thomas who
phoned us we don't know who he is he was
very
shady but we're learning more about him
and i think that maybe he might be like
our dad or something
oh you know what
all right
come on find something
ah that's for the globe perfect
oh we can make a face with it it's like
uh mr potato head
nope
uh
swap the lips and the eyes around don't
we
there we go it looks pretty funny
[Music]
there we go another injunction
maybe you can show me a way out of here
can we go out that way
[Music]
so
aha
i love this melody it reminds me of my
childhood at least the good
parts of it but the bad pawns
they're always there aren't they
you're a very smart girl lily
you know that don't you you're
special her voice is that
sadness
sadness is a very special gown oh if we
find the rest of the music notes
the spark's too weak to absorb why it's
like it's
missing something you gotta play a
beautiful tape
too
okay and through that door
will be
the missing piece
let's go
yeah because there was that thing in
here that i could
come on richard you were always there
when i needed you
let me return the favor uh i don't know
thomas what about my work the university
richard i know they kicked you out i'm
guessing you finally managed to piss off
the right people
stay with us old friend do it for me
for them so he brought him here
wonder who he meant by then
yeah it's it for me but then
that should be all the pieces of the
score now
[Music]
perfect
once he got engaged we grew apart for a
while
now that i think of it i guess i was
jealous i no longer had him
all for myself in time i warmed up to
her as well
she was striking both in her beauty and
intellect eventually
i accepted the fact that he had found
true happiness
true love strong and pure well
as pure as it can be i guess in any case
i was no longer needed when the project
came along
the one that would eventually be known
as nima i pulled all
my strings to get him what he wanted
even though i knew
it would be it would drive an even
bigger wedge between us
i wanted the best for him he was the
closest to as closest to his son
that i'd ever had
well it sounds at the end of things good
times
so that's how you found him yes
he was just lying there he uh
that's a reckon i'm sorry
he was a friend i just
need a moment that's not true thomas
you thought he deserved it
[Music]
yes there are definitely well there's
some sort of like big monster thing here
michael is
it's not just little ghosts
and memories there's definitely
creepier things going on here
should we go out there now no i'll go oh
no we can't because we have to go to the
piano
right
uh i'll probably be heading off soon
just heads up
let's go to the piano
[Music]
i do have my baby
uh
it's after life
what the [ __ ] is our massive hand
high five
me
nothing over here
so weird just looking back and forth
between
different viewports
hello hands
oh nice
must be one of richard's paintings
oh no it's sadness uncle richard
my arms are getting tired you've been
drawing me for
hours almost done
that's considered that this very reminds
me of someone
a girl i knew when i was very young
did you love her yes
with a young innocent love free of the
ferocity of adult lives
richard i'm getting a weird vibe from
him
there's grief sorrow
and something else
i think he likes to live vicariously
through others hopefully it's
nothing more than that's
why are you leading me i haven't
finished exploring yeah
wait i'll get the monkey
oh i thought it was one of those like
coughing monkeys but it's not
okay
aren't you a bit old to be playing with
dolls
here i bought it especially for you
oh a ribbon it's beautiful
thank you uncle richard yeah let me
um on the other hand why don't you do it
yourself
ah what was that it's like something
stirred inside him
oh god no i don't want to go down this
path
oh no i hope it's not what i think it is
but i haven't finished exploring this
side so i'm just gonna quickly
pop over here
i was finished they had to let me go
me richard tarkowski
whose work were recognized across the
continent
whose imagination as they said knew no
bounds it wasn't your imagination was it
richard whose very name became
synonymous with fine art
all of that meant nothing to these
soulless
bureaucrats wait maybe this is why he
was asked to leave
oh god this is so bad to them
i was just a liability the source of
dangerous
liberal ideas i felt betrayed
empty i needed to get out away from the
hollow sickness of the city
but most of all i needed a friend and so
i sought him out
i knew his wife who died some months
earlier oh okay
oh okay i think thomas was saying how
he like was lost without her or
something so that makes sense
at the time i thought it best not to
interfere with this grieving
and so now i feared that he'd hold it
against me
for not being there when he leave me the
most
instead he offered me at home thomas is
a decent guy it seems
been through a lot
but richard on the other hand
richard
where are you taking me over here
here's the ribbon
no i didn't mean to
oh god what have i
done it feels
cold
what have you done
he didn't kill her did he
uh
i had never felt anything so
desperate
it was calling out to me it wanted to
show me something
[Music]
god [ __ ] dammit
i thought i could protect her idiot
what would you think of me i failed you
i failed us
is this thomas
it's all falling apart our love
is lasting i think it said
what
yes i know
no i need to be sure there's
got to be something around here
you want what
[ __ ]
richard torkowski was on the wall behind
him
is he in his own flat then or is he in
richards for that
oh what's this
[Music]
look who finally decided to let me out
of my
cage and only when you need my
help surprise
surprise you know what i'm not in the
mood
just tell me what you see what come on
come on
yes i can feel it okay
it's around here how come they're like
different people
oh that's real [ __ ] specific hey i'm
trying to help here
you know sometimes i wonder well it
doesn't make it easier when you keep me
in the dark for so long
thanks for that by the way i love a way
to treat your soul mate
god damn it
there's nothing here
there is really i'm never wrong about
these things
you know that oh screw this
i should have known better than to
listen to you
wait what
there there where
what what's that richard
they look alike
[Music]
this is it
okay
[Music]
tension grab the [ __ ] thing would you
shut up
[Music]
okay
oh
[Music]
it's like he's obsessed
what is it
what have i done
[Music]
we couldn't have known him
by letting him into my home
he was like a father to me how could he
do this to her
[ __ ] bastard who could he
i told you we couldn't trust anyone but
ourselves
keep it together think
what do we do now
we wait when he comes back
oh just easy tiger
remember what's at stake here
just let me do
what i do
you better do it fast
because if you don't
i will kill him
the controller vibrated on kill him
okay so it seems like thomas is kind of
the same
is in the same situation but he split
off
into like two different people
constantly i guess she started to do
that
actually thomas not the same time
i wasn't expecting you
is uh everything all right my friend
[Music]
did you do it friend did i
what my daughter
my thirteen-year-old daughter
i entrusted her to you thomas
did you do it i
i don't
i found a sketchbook
forced myself to look through it
cover to cover every single
[ __ ] page
tell me you didn't hurt her richard
thomas please tell me i'm wrong richard
tell me and i'll let you go i it wasn't
me
thomas you have to understand
there's a sting inside of me shut up
[Music]
you have to believe me i wanted to die
i'll make it quick thomas i'm
so sorry she's my
daughter i never wanted any of this
i should never have come here
you'll
what the [ __ ]
there it's like a
dog
time to cut it out
oh i am a boy
cool but we will save playing as
thomas for next week
thank you so much for watching
that was really interesting i'm very
i'm i'm slightly confused but i'm sure
we'll find out more as we play
as we play along um
i hope i hope that well i don't know
this sounds really bad
but i hope that richard did kill his son
uh his son his daughter because uh
yeah if it was something else and that
could be
well it's all very bad but you know you
know what i mean
i don't know it's very suggestive right
now so you just got to kind of make a
bit what you will
but it's pretty freaking dark either way
uh and it's interesting to find out that
so i don't think we are actually thomas
daughter or maybe we are maybe there's
multiple but
sadness is thomas's daughter right
that's that's sad that's sad and it
makes sense why she's
afraid to see everybody
things getting spicy yes they are
submissive yes they are
uh but yeah thanks so much for watching
i'm really really
enjoying the cinematics in this as well
i knew
i was thinking before i started playing
again i was wondering whether there
would be like a big
big bad boss uh kind of like um you know
pyramid head
in san hill i was like it's the sun hill
inspired game there's got to be some
sort of
big bad boss and there you go
we found out today so yeah and
i i enjoy that it's not just a big like
i am scary and angry we got introduced
to it
crying and telling us not to look at it
which i i don't i always find it free
here when they have
a range of emotions that aren't just a
fear
and um you know
bravado just no i'm just feared
i'm just anger and uh verado if they if
they can
show complexity it's like oh damn
uh but anyway i am gonna go now i'll see
you guys
next week at around 8 30
9 p.m gmt to play more of this